ils sont arrivés confiants pour une
audience d'à peine 30 minutes pour
plaider la levée du contrôle judiciaire
de muriel bolle qui l'obligent à vivre
éloigné des vosges depuis le mois d'août
pour ses avocats il est temps de
desserrer l'étreinte judiciaire les
investigations techniques scientifiques
les auditions de témoins ont eu lieu
plus rien n'empêche son retour ses
vérifications semble-t-il en tête et
fait même si elle ne figure pas dans le
dossier
donc il me semble qu'aujourd'hui on peut
rêver en revenir à une situation normale
et permettre à muriel bolle de rentrer
dans les vosges et d'avoir à nouveau une
vie familiale normale
et si de leur côté les jacob sont
rentrés chez eux
c'était après une audition devant la
juge une audition qui n'a toujours pas
eu lieu pour muriel bolle depuis sa mise
en examen pour enlèvement
voilà pourquoi le parquet s'est opposée
et a demandé qu'elles restent dans la
nièvre
muriel bolle ne va pas bien elle a très
mal vécu la période de noël qui est une
période normalement de joie dans la
chaleur familiale
alors bien sûr elle a pu être entouré
par certains des siens mais elle n'était
plus dans son cadre familial donc nous
souhaitons véritablement que ce contrôle
judiciaire soit soit levée la chambre de
l'instruction rendra sa décision sur la
levée du contrôle judiciaire ce mercredi
à 9 heures
par ailleurs les avocats de muriel bolle
ont demandé à ce qu'une reconstitution
soit organisé sur place et il attend
toujours qu'une audience soient fixés
sur leur demande d'annulation de la mise
en examen de muriel bolle